هنا
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بعد حمله شنطه سلطات في
11 ولايه الشرطه الالمانيه تعتقل اكثر من
25 شخصا بينهم جنود سابقون وبرلمانيه
سابقه ينتمون لمجموعه من اقصى اليمين
بتهمه الاعدادي لاسقاط الدوله
ردا على رفع الجزيره ملف اغتيال الزميله
شيرين ابو عاقله الى الجنائيه الدوليه
مسؤولون اسرائيليون يدعون الى سحب اعتماد
صحفي الشبكه العاملين داخل الخط الاخضر
كما دعا زعيم حزب القوه اليهوديه اليمني
المتطرف لتمار بن كبير الى طردهم ملتهما
اياهم بمعادله الثانيه
شراكه جديده بين واشنطن في مجال الطاقه
يهدف طرفان خلالها الى تعزيز الامني وخفض
الاسعار رئيس الوزراء البريطاني يؤكد ان
البلدين يقفان معا في وجه بوتن ويعملان
على تقليل الاعتماد العالمي على انجازات
طاقه الروسيه تقول انها تبحث خيارات
مختلفه للرد على فرد سقفا لسعر نفسها
المغرب يصنع تاريخا عربيا جديدا في
المونديال بعد تاهله الى ربع النهائي على
حساب اسبانيا بركلات الترجيح وتالق الحارس
ياسين بونو انتصار اسود الاطلس مازال
يتصدر من الصوت التواصل وتغريداتي رواده